if we want politics to be the kind of
arena where you're attracting and
encouraging really competent people who
do a job well because that's what
they're supposed to do then you have to
pay them a salary that's commensurate
with that if I want to hire a software
engineer at Google to be world-class or
if I want to hire someone at a bank or
someone at an environmental firm or
someone at a utility that I want to be
really really really good I don't say
well you know I'll let these people kind
of pick themselves with the popular vote
and then I won't pay them very much and
I'll just see how they do and Singapore
is probably the best example Singapore
pays its elected officials a lot of
money on par with what you'd make as you
know a bank or a lawyer a management
consultant or something like that and so
that changes a the pool of people you
are drawing from and B the way that
people feel about the job it's no longer
like well I got into this Republic
service but it's really hard to serve
the public so I'll serve myself a little
bit and then I'll do the job in order to
enrich myself now or later instead you
have a bunch of people who treat it like
a real profession our politics is in
fact not very professional even though
it appears to be from the outside then
additionally I would like to say well
you know would it be nice to reward
politicians or officials government
officials if they actually do a good job
because right now they get paid exactly
the same whether they do really well or
do nothing or do really poorly so what
about this what about let's say for
every piece of legislation for every
project or for every panel that you're
involved in why don't we put some
measurables on it right right why don't
we decide what are the goals what are we
trying to accomplish with this new piece
of let's say education legislation and
if let's say our goal is to raise the
test scores of US children by 10
percentage points that's our goal right
why don't we put a timeframe on it let's
say 10 years from now that's our goal
well I would love nothing more as a
citizen and as a taxpayer to say that
you know Secretary of Education Arne
Duncan let's say he's responsible for
this plan and he's got let's say a
200 or 500 people working with him I
would love to treat that like a project
like a goal that's got a deliverable and
if they reach that goal 10 years and now
long after he's Secretary of Education
will write him a check
I would love to rate Arne Duncan a check
for 2 million dollars from the US
taxpayers for having taken a job and
done it well and accomplished a goal
that's the way the real world works
right you get hired based on how good
you are you get paid based on how well
you do if you don't do well you get
fired or you get paid less if we treated
politics like more of a profession like
it should be we would all be a lot
better off